okay you are presenting last year you're
performing tonight
what can the BTS army expect well no I
mean the boy that's this girl I'll work
dance I'm ready
perform for you army I love so much
thank you you guys are all loved and I
know you love doing Old Town Road what
are you gonna bring to that stage with
Billy Ray Cyrus and lil not um we had ly
rehearsals like 10 times we have some
little moves together with we're little
NAS we saw he dancing and he knows
really out of dance so like you know
please stay tuned for the moves and our
voices - how does it feel for you like
Michelle said presenting and now
performing things just keep getting
better you're here at the Grammys is
this emotional reflective um actually
miss said it like like last year we just
said it like spitted will be back and
like I thought the presents and thought
never it'll never come true but I think
this is the reason why you should just
speak out your ambitions you know it
comes true maybe maybe spoke it into
existence I was told that if I got to
interview you guys I should say I purple
you how we say our love new music right
guys what can the fans expect new music
we just released Lex whan it's a first
single for our upcoming album we release
our album like in February what's it
gonna be like it's gonna be harder it's
gonna be whatever you're expecting it is
it's gonna be bad
and harder what do you mean harder it's
really hard the hardest hardest we can
go does that mean emotional like your
real lives what is that um we've been
always personal and friend and our
messages and tracks and the new
performance I think that's that's the
bus will wind up here with you guys but
ariana grande and you in rehearsals
together yes what can you tell us about
working with her and then getting to
know her um you know she's she's the one
right now like she's the one she's like
so like when like Ariana's just just
practicing like next to our big studio
was like we just knew it and she said
she wanna she wanted to see our
rehearsals and what we're doing and we
we show the showed her like she was like
she was spitting some bad words like and
we saw her we ourselves too and so we
know why we were doing tonight what
she's doing tonight in here it was like
the greatest you've seen it we've seen
it it's amazing that I'm not 100% but it
was amazing you love Ariana yeah we
purple Ariana are you guys real quick I
know you have so many fans but you also
people who come at you how do you deal
with that online like how do you keep
each other solid when you do deal with
haters and how do you persevere through
that because you're so positive
you know if there's light there's always
shadow right so I think you cannot
always like concentrate on those bad
words if you keep dude keep doing that I
mean like I'll be scared like to be like
standing on this like interview to like
even now like somebody I'm you know my
ears are really itching because
somebody's like hating right now like on
on Twitter or you know anywhere well you
know we have our fans and they purple us
and with that we can't get
[Music]